yes what's up this is andrew for
10senses.com so in this video i would
like to talk about the global market we
have a lot of things happening
so i'm going to make a focus on the spy
etf which is the tracker of the s p 500
let's get into it
[Music]
oh right guys so i'm not making a lot of
analysis on the spy but actually i
always always talk about it on my
discord it's something i always keep an
eye on because it's the global market
this is telling you what is going to
happen
on the other stocks are the breakouts
going to be successful or not it brings
you a lot of information so
i always analyze this index and i want
to share more this analysis with you
guys on youtube because i think that we
are in a period where it's important to
keep an eye on this and not just trade
blindly so i use elliot wave theory i
use breakouts i use divergences so this
is what we are going to see here
i'm just gonna analyze the move since
2020 so here i'm gonna break down this
move into five waves on the upside so
one
two
right we are in the third the force is
coming all right so i think the force is
actually we are in the force wave right
now i'm gonna analyze this very soon
we're gonna have a force wave that we
i'm gonna tell you i think where it
might button and then we're gonna have a
fifth wave that same thing i'm gonna
tell you where i think it might go so
first edius theory applied we just
checked quickly guys that you know the
waves are the wave counting is good
one two three four five okay that works
right here one two three four five that
works and we are in the fifth of the
fifth of the third so we completed that
all right i didn't i was not sure if the
fifth was going there or or not okay i
was sending alerts on my discord saying
that around 480 490 it is a level to
sell the s p 500 i personally missed
this trade around this levels but i got
in around 472 something like this and i
increased my position two days ago to a
short position because i have stocks of
course and i want to be protected for
what is coming so what is telling us
that the situation is shifting the first
thing let's quickly so it seems that we
are the third wave and that the third
wave is complete but let's be honest
eliot theory by itself is very very hard
to find the right counting at the first
try so we associate that with
divergences so here we can see for
example at the end the market making
high highs the rsi going lower let me
add the macd guys here
[Music]
same thing macd making lower highs all
right market making high highs 90 making
low highs the market is out of steam
bulls are tired let's quickly have a
look at the volume usually volume are
decreasing in this period
here it was not obvious guys
not obvious at all the volume were
stable so we didn't have the information
coming from the volume but we had the
information coming from the momentum
then another thing you guys are used to
i mean use maybe to use uh bullish
irregular divergences but another one
that is very useful
and
here i can see right away it's not here
is the hidden divergence right so human
divergences occur whenever the market is
in uptrend and the momentum is uh making
lower so the market is making higher
lows and the momentum is making lower uh
yes lower lows so that it takes energy
all right so you have this kind of shape
uh with the momentum that is decreasing
okay and the market is making high highs
as at the beginning you don't have the
bearish divergence so we have a mega fan
pattern i'm just going to keep the
magazine guys
it's easier and you can see the magazine
in a healthy trend is actually
developing into a megaphone pattern all
right as you guys can see here so when
you have this megaphone pattern in the
trend you know that the trend is strong
strong because you don't have bearish
divergences and healthy whenever you
don't have this anymore so here we had
it until here all right and you can see
that this trend line okay so i'm
connecting this
this low here so when i was here the
market was making high lows and the macd
was making lower lows but so we were
rebuilding energy starting from here
sorry ma'am and when we arrive here
again on this trend line you can see
that here the market didn't have time to
go lower the momentum didn't have time
to go lower with a market that is coming
on the trend line all right so this was
the first signal that this trend line
might break okay
and it's the signal to me
that we are studying the force
corrective wave the second corrective
wave was a flat as you can see here abc
in september and october november 20. so
we can expect a zigzag because usually
when you have a flat in the second wave
you have a zigzag in the false wave
that's a rule that elliot had identified
a long time ago already so i think we
had a wave of this zigzag so once again
then you can see here the macd was
making a megaphone pattern and then
suddenly it
converges so this is a momentum bearish
signal so momentum marriage signal
breakout and elliot wave suggesting that
we might be done with the third wave so
i have a lot of information that
actually and the rates are increasing
you guys are aware of that the 10 year
is going really really high guys
us 10 year you can have a look at that
okay so oh okay we are correcting a bit
but this rally of the tenure is
suggesting that inflation is here all
right it's showing you that traders are
pressing inflation and so we the fed is
talking in five days so let's see what
jerome pogba has to say but most likely
you know his rate policy is not going to
slow the the rate uh hike policy is not
going to slow so this is what the market
is fearing all right so the question is
so we are in a correction guys okay it's
probably gonna last
it's been already one month so maybe one
more month maybe two more months maybe
three more months you know i think
something like this i would say two
three months so we're probably gonna
have an abc the question is is the a
wave complete so let's find some
supports so as you guys know whenever we
have a correction it usually goes to the
top of the third or bottom of the force
so let's check of the preceding wave
counting so let's check here
third wave is here guys force wave is at
420 so either we go to 450 or to 420
we broke 450 yesterday and it was too
close from the breakout of the
streamline
so my take and let's do some fibs
okay
and you see the 38.2
usually we correct at least 238.2
otherwise it's not really a correction
all right sometimes it goes to the 23.6
in very strong bull markets but i think
we're not anymore in a very strong bull
market for the past six months already
and so i my take is that we go to 420.
so the question is are we gonna do it
right away for the a wave and then even
maybe go deeper or maybe do a flat or
are we going to go a little bit lower
for the airwave correct and then see
wait i think the second scenario is the
most likely one we have the 200-day
moving average coming at 440. so i think
we might just
find some support at this moving average
maybe bounce a little bit but then guys
here it would be the time to take
profits on i think many
stocks if you have some i would
personally do that because then we have
the c wave coming all right the c wave
might end in april something like this
and depending on the air wave we're
gonna analyze the c wave today is too
early to say and then the good thing
about that is that this is only a false
wave yeah so we're gonna have a massive
rally starting maybe in june 22 you know
so we have six months
where i think we need to be cautious we
need to be careful bitcoin is gonna
follow i'm gonna do another video on
bitcoin so that's it for uh dspy i hope
you guys enjoyed this video and if you
did please don't forget to click on the
sub like and bell button so you're gonna
be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to shore
i'll see you guys